réservé aux cyclistes et aux piétons le
pont est fermé aux autos fini le bruit
de la circulation et la traversée
dangereuse pour les cyclistes dans le
monde entier comme à montréal des voies
urbaines sont fermées ou réduite et des
centaines de pistes cyclables sont
ouvertes
la bicyclette la petite reine comme on
l'appelait a rarement porté aussi bien
son nom les marchands de vélos du monde
entier sont débordés ah non c'est même
très avancées
présentement on peut facilement attirer
qu'on a presque deux tiers de la saison
fait à 5,6 d'année alors que ça
normalement ça commence normalement on
serait peut-être à mi-chemin des vélos
il y en a à tous les prix les moins
chers par les plus vite
alors qu'est ce qui te parle plus
maintenant est-ce que c'est comme
d'habitude c'est à dire les vélos
hybrides des vélos hybrides de très bien
entre 500 et 900 dollars
on est presque en pénurie et les fous de
ça aussi il ya une pénurie de stocks
présentement si c'est pour nous de
pouvoir acheter des vélos au sérieux à
son petit ce ne sont pas vendus ils sont
avant mai
encore une semaine ou deux et peut-être
convoitait tant on ne prévoit pas
d'autres arrivages avant le milieu de
l'été
alors il y a les vélos haut de gamme en
y mettant le prix
beaucoup de gens qui viennent depuis
qu'ils nous disent ça fait dix ans je
peux faire du vélo mais v tant que j'ai
pas fait de vélo puis la wii là on fait
du vélo c'est une année exceptionnelle
mais comme on ne change pas de vélo tous
les ans michel compte investir
prudemment l'an prochain ceci dit il
reste le service et les réparations 30%
du chiffre d'affaires
le monde du vélo et peut-être à l'aube
d'un grand virage levé jouit montceau
mal sur les découvrir ou le redécouvrir
en prenant les habituels le monde
connaît le pays aux attentes elle
m'apprend d'une habitude mais c'est
autre chose et peut-être que ce soit
complétée secours d'utiliser compris
comme nouveau moindre un sport rugby
d'autant plus qu'on découvre le vélo
avec assistance électrique
une révolution pour gens plus âgés ou
moins sportifs puissent ouvert ce convoi
la personne qui va chez le vélo à
assistance électrique qui roule deux il
y en a un des deux qui peut faire un 100
km bien dans les 229 la personne à
castans électro bon poursuivre son
compagnon le vélo et fabre 100 km avec
la sauce électrique avec la même femme
les usines à vélo de taiwan roule à
plein régime et s'attendent à ce que le
marché du vélo électrique double d'ici
cinq ans on parle de 25 milliards de
dollars électrique ou pas taiwan est en
train de redevenir le numéro un mondial
du vélo avec le retour de la production
de la chine continentale en raison de
l'augmentation de ses salaires et des
récents conflits commerciaux avec pékin
bien sûr michelle est satisfait on est
bien chanceux de toi franchement
ces bâtiments clés dans cette situation
là mais ils sympathisent avec les
commerçants les plus touchées par l'aco
vide jean michel leprince sera du canada
à montréal